well it was kind of a two-part process
of finding Francis the first part being
the writing part that I did with Noah
which took about a year and then after
that it was finding her as an actor and
for me they're two very different things
and the writing part we really found her
together by writing scenes and listening
to her talk and that sounds really goofy
but it's true it's almost like you write
its it suppose like you take down the
voices in your head were you guys having
conversations about oh I have this idea
for this film about this about this
young woman transitioning from post
college to adulthood he won it we wanted
to make a movie that I did know I
thought that I could be in that we could
make but we I we started out with a list
of ideas that were just kind of like
little moments or characters or dialogue
exchanges and then that grew into what
it became but I it wasn't really about
me it was about this character that
emerged from the writing and I I mean I
think we were both interested in that
moment of like you're too far out of
college for this to be cute anymore
you're now almost 30 it's over pack it
up regretted I made greenberg together
and credit acted in it but then I want I
thought be fun to do something else and
I was kind of just exploring that idea
with Greta I mean initially and then we
started it turned it into this script
but I wasn't I mean of course because I
have a different perspective on it and
maybe that's why it's in black and white
because it's historical for me but i but
i but even that was more instinctive I
just had a very clear idea about what
this could be at the same time that I
had no idea what it was going to turn
out to be I just i we kind of really did
just listen to it and follow it and we
weren't thinking and broad strokes about
even about oh this is about being 27
this is about female friendship I mean
these things all came in the best way I
think
writing is going well which was from
exploration probably most directors want
at some point try to make a movie in
black and white and but I think it feels
a little nostalgic in a way yeah it's
period that you've already passed but
it's kind of looking back on it and the
story and the character felt so
contemporary and Greta is so present and
there it you know and I thought it
should be funny and joyful and light and
romantic and and though the the feeling
of youth and and you know modern love
and and I always like to bring personal
stuff into the movies even if it has no
actual bearing I mean I made a movie
called the squid in the whale which had
personal stuff in a more kind of overt
way and I addressed Jeff Daniels and my
dad's clothes and that that was I like
to do that anyway you know to bring
stuff that I have connection to I mean
even shooting a bass are here because I
went to Vassar it brought stuff up for
me that have nothing to do with the
actual scenes we're shooting but I just
feel it's like I think it's a good
creative space to be in and so New York
City is that for me because I every
street I have some feeling about and
particularly Brooklyn where I grew up
and it's a it's a place I love working
and I mean obviously it's a beautiful
city
- and shooting it in black and white
does this whole other thing because
there's a tradition of New York in black
and white I think that's it it's like a
kind of it's like having a you know like
putting my dad's corduroy jacket on
somebody I mean I was proud of the
writing and I thought it was a really
good script and I think that there's
always a fear when you take on something
as an actor I think right before you
start you think what if I'm not the
right person for this and it's really
good and I don't want to mess it up and
and I think I was experiencing that with
my with this this thing that we wrote
and I think a lot of the way that I
discovered her was through the other
actors that we cast Micky Sumner who
plays Sophie and Mike's Egan and Adam
driver and Charlotte Dan Bois they all
were so great and they were so well well
cast and specifically cast and really
great actor
and I feel that they what they gave me
allowed me to find the parameters of
what Francis was and when Sophia when
Mickey auditioned for Sophie suddenly
when I was acting against her it was
like there's Francis she came out to
play because that's Sophie and I felt
like that was a big part of it and then
also the way Noah shot the movie was it
it wasn't far away but it was far enough
away that I could kind of do a full body
performance that I wasn't just acting
with my face or my voice it felt like it
could really be embodied and I think
getting that entire physicality of who
Francis was from her clogs to her
backpack to her bomber was and then
making a run it really that's that's who
she was and then all the sudden she was
there but sometimes you don't get to
find the full body version of a
character because you never get to
really do a scene all the way out in a
space with enough freedom and so it was
really it felt just full and big as a
character right but I I don't have I
really enjoy stepping back and being an
actor in something I just always feel a
little when you write it and you act in
it it feels like making a cake and
eating the cake that you just made all
by yourself and that feels gladness